[Musique]
merci Pascal saveline de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu du valdemarne
membre du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste kanaki c'est le
nouveau nom de votre groupe on va
évidemment revenir sur l'actualité du
Sénat dans quelques instants mais
d'abord on va longuement parler de la
situation en Israël et de cette
allocution d'Emmanuel Macron hier avant
de rentrer dans le détail qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé du discours du chef de
l'État est-ce qu'il a trouvé les mots
justes pour vous
écoutez
d'abord je vous dis ça avec toujours de
l'émotion on est
vendredi
euh notre humanité est touchée là de
plein fouet et je pense qu'il est
extrêmement important de de se
reconnaître dans toutes les victimes
toutes les victimes israéliennes bien
sûr les victimes
palestiniennes puis nos compatriotes
aussi donc je dis ça parce
que on peut pas choisir les victimes là
franchement mais vous avez l'impression
que c'est ce qu'il a fait lui je pense
qu'il fallait il fallait parler de
toutes les
victimes regardez votre reportage
l'immense majorité sont des
civil donc je dis ça parce que c'est ça
êre emprunt d'humanité après le
président de la République hier soir a a
rappelé et c'était bien une position
originale qui était celle de la solution
et la seule solution qu'on connaissait
avant cette terreur c'est la solution
des deux états c'est c'est c'est la
solution de droit international c'est
c'est la
solution de sécurité pour tous pour ces
deux peuples le peuple palestinien le
peuple israélien mais ça c'est ce qu'il
a dit il dit la lutte contre le
terrorisme ne peut pas remplacer la
recherche de la paix ah non mais ça il
faut
franchement cette position elle est
indispensable
elle est indispensable moi j'ai apprécié
évidemment il faut aujourd'hui s'occuper
et et et mettre tous les moyens
diplomatiques mobiliser le le voyez le
tout le monde au plan international pour
aller libérer les otages quelle que soit
leur nationalité il faut ouvrir une
perspective c'est pas la vengence de feu
uneence
de naniaou il n'a qu'une idée en tête
c'est venger Israël é radiquer le Hamas
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'on peut faire des
négociations de paix en ce moment on
peut pas on peut pas avoir une vengeance
àog
regardez il y a toutes les victimes
quasiment sont des civils donc c'est une
vengeance qui va être àveugle et
là-dessus Emmanuel Macron a dit il a dit
il a appelé à une réponse forte et
juste l'initiative for juste est-ce que
c'est un message à Israël pour dire il
ne faut pas aller trop loin il a a dit
il faut protéger les civils c'est ça une
démocratie ben évidemment qu'il faut
protéger les
civils il faut qu'il y ait il faut qu'il
y ait une initiative une mobilisation
internationale d'une grande ampleur il
faut réunir l'ensemble des nations-
Unies pas seulement le Conseil de
sécurité l'ensemble des nations pour
qu'on fasse respecter le droit
international on peut pas rester
contentre occidentaux ou seulement au
Conseil de sécurité il faut qu'on ait
une mobilisation internationale pour la
paix à l'échelle de la nation des
nations
et là qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire tous
les leviers doivent être utilisés pour
libérer les otages et il faut aller vite
il faut aller vite là c'est on entend
des des un embrasement un embrasement
terrible faut libérer les otages il faut
aussi ouvrir une
perspective regardez la la guerre peut
pas la guerre la guerre la guerre la
vengeance à ne va pas amener une
solution mais c'est pas du tout ce qu'
dit le chef de l'éur est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord aager toutes les forces
dans le monde tous les États dans le
monde qui veulent libérer ces otages
négocier et discuter et obtenir leur
libération voilà et dans le même moment
dans le même mouvement il faut ouvrir
une perspective et la perspective c'est
c'est c'est pas c'est c'est de justement
d'ouvrir une perspective laquelle que
c'est c'est par exemple réouvrir cette
question avec plus de
fermeté ça fait il y a eu combien de
résolution qu'on réaffirmé qu'il y ait
ces deux états l'État d'Israël et l'état
de la Palestine là je vous le dis j'ai
j'ai j'ai j'ai mal au ventre on a une
part de responsabilité tous ça fait des
décennies qu'on le sait cette situation
qu'on n pas voulu résoudre où des
résolutions nont pas été appliqué donc
faut aller faut y mettre toute sa
détermination et aller chercher tout le
monde dans cette affaire et ouvrir une
perspective c'est libérer aussi des
prisonniers politiques je je le dis là
avec passion mais il faut sortir ceux
qui sont du côté du progrès qui sont des
démocrates il faut sortir les
prisonniers politiques si on veut battre
le Hamas il faut sortir les prisonniers
politiques le Hamas c'est tout le
contraire de la démocratie c'est tout le
contraire de l'émancipation des femmes
voyez ce que je organisation terroriste
pour vous est-ce que vous vous la
qualifiez d'organisation terroriste
c'est une organisation islamique qui a
commis des actes terroristes je crois
que les choses sont claires dans mes
propos on va dire un dernier mot après
on va parler des conséquences du conflit
en France mais on a appris ce matin que
l'UNU avait été informé par Israël de
l'ordre d'vac plus d'un million de
personnes du nord de Gaza vers le sud
d'ici 24 he c'est le site que signe que
la reposte est imminente pour
vous vous avez vu ce que dit aussi l'ONU
c'est c'est impossible l'ONU demande à
Israël de renoncer à cette ordre
d'évacuation on a bombardement sur
bombardement aveugle
franchement je dis ça je vous dis ça
avec passion parce que je suis meurtri
moi je vous le dis très vraiment avec
une très grande sincérité mais les
bombardements à ça n'a fait que tu es
des civils ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
une vérité donc il y a à un moment donné
euh engager une telle occupation là en
ayant coupé depuis 3 jours l'eau
l'électricité l'alimentation mais on va
un désastre c'est un cycle infernal on
est en train d'org enfin s'organise un
un cycle un cercle de la terreur vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est ça ça
peut pas ça peut pas bien se terminer il
faut pas se raconter l'histoire voilà il
va y avoir plein d'innocents qui vont
perdre qui vont perdre leur vie et moi
je m'excuse mais voyez
c'est il faut pas confondre les peuples
et les forces politiques et les états
regardez en Israël il y avait eu des
très grandes mobilisations par rapport à
la décision de confusion avec la Cour
suprême regardez en dans la bande de
Gaza vous pouvez regarder les yeux dans
les yeux toutes les enfants palestiniens
les femmes palestiniennes les
Palestiniens et leur dire les yeux dans
les yeux vous êtes au
Hamas tous les Palestiniens ne sont pas
Hass donc on peut pas avoir ce
bombardement aveugle voyez on va tuer
des innocents on va parler de essu du
discours d'Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État qui a également dit qu'il ne peut
y avoir de 8 mai je le cite ce qui
confondent la cause palestinienne et la
justification du terrorisme commettent
une faute morale politique et
stratégique forte il visait notamment la
France insoumise écoutez euh déjà fa
avir de la clarté dans les propos je
crois que vous me connaissez je suis un
homme de conviction là je parle avec
passion euh le le président de la
République il peut pas lui le faire et
d'autres aussi enfin franchement mais il
a pas eu raison de dire ça pas d'accord
avec cette phrase écoutez écoutez non
mais juste sur cette PHAs ce qui se
passe là ce qui se passe là franchement
ça mérite de la dignité ça mérite de la
rigueur politique on ne peut pas on peut
pas
impor peut pas importer les débats
politicos français avec je ne sais
quelle intention derrière là l'urgence
c'est pas les débats politiciens et le
débat local c'est là national là ce
qu'il faut c'est trouver des solutions
et tout le
monde au propos quand vous dites on
importe les problèmes politiques ça vise
la France insoumise ou ça vise le chef
de l'État mais ça vise mais ça vise le
chef de l'État lui faites pas dire ce
qu'il a pas dit il avait l'air un peu
coincé quand même notre chef de l'État C
exactement ce qu'il a
dit mais c'est vous qui citez ce qu'il
l'a pas dit excusez-moi Oran non je vous
demande si vous disez la France
insoumise la France insoumise ou mais la
France insoumise c'est pas l'adversaire
de la solution quand même on voit bien
qu'on a un problème qui est d'une toute
autre nature on va pas importer un
conflit politique en France sur un
conflit donc pour vous que eux ne
qualifient pas le Hamas d'organisation
terroriste c'est pas un problème mais
écoutez on on joue sur les franchement
franchement on cherche quoi là on
cherche quoi on cherche à arbitrer quoi
non on cherche à savoir quelle est votre
position pour moment moi j'ai été très
clair et je pense que c'est c'est cette
clarteté là qui qui doit nous rassembler
donc le Hamas est une organisation
islamique politique politique islamiste
elle a commis des actes terroristes elle
doit être jugée comme organisation et
tous ses membres par la Cour
internationale voyezut faut être faut
être attentif à tous ces mots à tous ces
vocabulaires là est-ce que la prise de
position de la France insoumise et
notamment de Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
aujourd'hui un problème pour l'anub vous
êtes allié avec la France insoumise au
sein de l'anub vous le Parti communiste
est-ce vous pouvez le rester et c'est
c'est ce qui enfin je j'avoue que
franchement je suis un peu je suis un
peu en colère là franchement qu'on
insiste qu'on insiste qu'on insiste pour
vous c'est pas une question qu'on
insiste qu'on insiste Olivier fort dit a
un problème avec la méthode Mélenchon
marine Tondelier ce matin dit aussi que
la la prise de position va prendre un
problème au sein de laanupe vous vous
dites pas ça bah le le monsieur fort
pour le Parti socialiste s'exprime
madame Tondelier s'exprime chaque parti
s'exprime et Fabien Roussel est loin
d'être tendre avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
non mais là on n pas sur la tendresse
attendez on est est-ce que
vous là ça pose la prise de position de
la France insoumise pose un problème au
sein de la nuup ou pas ce qui pose un
problème c'est qu'on n pas respecté des
résolutions pendant des décennies et là
il y avait ni la France insoumise ni le
Parti communiste ni la Nupe ça fait des
décennies qu'il y a des résolutions 400
résolutions Orian qui demandaient
la qu'on est les deux états Israéliens
et Palestiniens qu'on arrête les
colonisations voilà le sujet voilà le
pas la question parce qu'elle SL donc
pour vous c'est pas un sujet on a j'ai
pas dit que c'est pas non non mais
attendez fait parlez pas quand même à ma
place vous répondez pas mais je réponds
pas parce que je pense que c'est pas le
sujet prioritaire c'est pas c'est pas
l'urgence du moment écoutez ces petites
polémiqu là on va aller on va continuer
à parler de ce sujet on va chez vous
dans votre département du valdearne on
retrouve Cécile Dubois bonjour Cécile
merci beaucoup beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédactrice en chef de 94 citoyens vous
êtes allé sonder les différents élus du
département sur cette question de
l'attaque contre
Israël oui bonjour oui les réactions
sont plutôt contrastées alors j'ai j'ai
lu j'ai regardé plutôt j'ai visionné
votre déclaration bonjour Pascal
sabodelli j'ai visionné votre
déclaration vous avez réagi vous par une
vidéo mot très précis très clair
effectivement qualifiant l'attaque du
Hamas de terroriste sans confondre ce
mouvement avec le peuple le Palestinien
et dénonçant également le comportement
colonisateur du gouvernement d'Israël
ben mais al j'ai j'ai bien lu j'ai bien
vu la votre échange euh sur le le le
caractère politicien de de certains
débats mais ce sujet ce sujet il suscite
aussi des réaction très contrasté un
débat très polarisé dans la société
est-ce que ce sujet divise aussi les
militants communistes dans le
département les militants que vous
rencontrez au quotidien les
sympathisants que vous rencontrez au
quotidien comment vous comment vous
gérez aussi ce ce débat en interne
j'entends bien toutes les propositions
que vous faites au niveau international
qui sont très claires aussi mais comment
concrètement avec les militants avec le
peuple français valdeemarnaet vous gérez
ce débat en
interne Cécile Dubois elle elle elle
connaît bien le le le valde Marne c'est
vrai que nous avons une très forte
tradition
euh c'est un c'est un notre département
euh
sur ces dernières décennies il a eu
beaucoup d'initiatives pour essayer de
de participer à la solution franchement
donc il y a il y a de la douleur il y a
de la colère il y a des fois du
fatalisme aussi parce que on le on
connaît le terme du problème moi écoutez
ce que je ressens c'est
que il il y a il y a une
recherche de de se vivre ensemble quoi
voilà et et je je pense que les hommes
et les femmes politiques aujourd'hui ont
une responsabilité c'est c'est d'évoquer
dans le débat et des fois dans le débat
contradictoire mais il faut s'obliger à
une
boussole trouver des solutions c'est
voyez c'est ça et et et les militants
les militants politiques de de gauche
mais même des gens de de droite sont
très préoccupés par la
situation très préoccupé donc tout le
monde va regarder qui qui joue dans dans
l'urgence c'est-à-dire de trouver des
solutions avec celle à caractère
immédiat et celle à plus long terme en
ouvrant une une perspective voilà
Emmanuel Macron hier il a il a mis en
garde contre un risque d'importation du
conflit dans notre pays dit ne menons
pas chez nous des aventures idéologiques
par imitation par projection Gérald
harmanin ind dit qu'il y a déjà plus
d'une centaine d'actes antisémites qui
ont été recensés depuis samedi est-ce
que vous craignez un regain
d'antisémitisme avec cette guerre en
Israël écoutez euh bien sûr que enfin
qui peut le souhaiter qui peut le
souhaiter c'est pour ça que nos paroles
politiques les uns et les autres et et
pas que les
politiques faut faire très attention à à
à ce que l'on on dit ce que l'on porte
comme
message euh moi je je m'enquère toujours
de la sécurité de de mes concitoyens et
vous êtes inquiet aujourd'hui tous tous
tous de tous quand je vous dis il faut
il faut se reconnaître dans dans dans
toutes les victimes quand je suis dans
mon département le valde mararne je je
ne choisis pas les valde mararnais je
les choisis pas mais sur ce regain
d'acte d'antisémitisme plus d'une
centaine en 4 jours c'est pas rien
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet Cécile
Dubois d'ailleurs je lui donner cette
information moi moi je me je me suis
renseigné auprès de Madame la préfète
hier
soir et à réponse de Madame la préfite à
ce sujet d'ailleurs c'est quoi
c'est voilà Monsieur le
bonsoir monsieur le sénateur nous sommes
très vigilants notamment sur les
messages qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux donc j'ai été aussi manqu rien
de la situation mais ils tiennent les
gens mais voyez c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure je vous dis notre cohésion et
notre unité elle tient mais elle va
tenir si on ouvre une perspective si on
fait terire les armes si on obtient le
cesser feu voyez ce que je veux dire et
si personne n'humilie personne Ccile
vous avez une autre question ah oui je
oui juste par rapport à vos priorités
puisque vous avez été réélu sénateur
vous êtes désormais le seul sénateur
communiste du département et donc vous
êtes le seul à porter justement le
communiste dans le département au Sénat
quell vont être vos priorités quelles
sont vos priorités vous avez commencé à
réagir là sur les logements mais quelles
sont vos priorités de de mandat puisque
vous êtes le dernier sénateur communiste
du
valdeemarne j'ai cru qu' vous alliez
faire une éloge funèbre c'est
mais bon voilà voyez dans ce moment un
peu de gravité c'est bien qu'on garde un
peu de un peu d'humour
d'abord le résultat des
sénatoriales c'est trois sénateurs de
gauche et trois sénateurs de droite donc
on n'est pas trop de trois donc au lieu
d'aller me cornériser dans un isolement
moi je vous le dis on est trois
sénateurs dans trois groupes différents
ici au Sénat
voilà il y a une puissance de réponse
possible sur mes priorité écoutez je
vous le savez mais je pense je l'ai
d'ailleurs dit encore là au Sénat dans
l'hémicycle sur le projet de loi sur des
nouveaux pouvoirs pour les maires pour
l'attribution des logements une demi
priorité c'est la question du logement
vous imaginez que dans mon département
le valdeemarne il y a 100000 demandeurs
de
logement qu'aujourd'hui en France on
construit entre 83 85000 logements par
an sur tout le territoire national donc
ça c'est c'est une des grandes priorités
c'est cette question du logement et
quand il il y aura le débat sur la loi
de finance on verra par exemple si on
vote ici au Sénat la TVA à 5,5 % pour la
construction de logements sociaux c'est
l'équivalent à peu près de 180 à 200000
logements sociaux qui pourrait être
construits voyez ça c'est le droit à
l'alimentation ça je pense que là il
faut avancer très fort sur cette
question et je vais continuer mon
travail sur l'ubérisation ça c'est
extrêmement important on est dans une
transformation du travail dans un
nouveau management du travail qui à mon
par sén du Sénat on remercie Cécile
Dubois merci beaucoup Cécile d'avoir été
avec nous l'actualité du Sénat cette
semaine c'était notamment ce débat qui a
eu lieu à l'initiative de votre groupe
sur la taxe foncière qui augmente pour
de nombreux Français on va voir comment
s'est passé cette séance avec Quentin
[Musique]
calm
bonjour bonjour parquell sa veent délier
et Quentin les avis de tax foncière ont
été envoyés fin septembre au
propriétaire il reste quelques jours
pour la payer pour la 2è année
consécutive les hausses sont fortes sur
cet impôt et elles font des bas
provoquant souvent l'incompréhension
exactement le taux avait déjà bondi
l'année dernière il a encore augmenté
cette année alors c'est dû déjà au
fonctionnement de cet impôt ce taux
grime de 7% au niveau national à cause
de son mode de calcul basé sur les
valeurs locatives et aussi lié à
l'inflation mais dans près de 15 % des
communes parqual vol Deli les maires ont
également choisi ou été obligé c'est
tout le débat d'augmenter le t fixé par
chaque ville la raison invoqué les
hausses des dépenses liées notamment au
traitement des fonctionnaires à
l'inflation et surtout au coût de
l'énergie pour les collectivités locales
on voit des exemples de fortte
augmentation cette année Paris c'est +
52 % Medon dans les hautes scènes 35 %,
Grenoble + 25 % ou une ville de droite 3
+ 9 % et dans ce contexte un bras de
faer oppose exécutif et collectivité
locale voilà chacun se renvoie la balle
depuis septembre sur les causes de ces
hausses de la taxe foncière on l'a
encore vu cette semaine au Sénat avec ce
débat que vous avez provoqué vous les
communistes dans l'hémicycle pour parler
de taxes foncières parce que le chef de
l'État a tenu des propos le 24 septembre
qui passent mal sur TF1 sur France 2 il
a dit quand vous avez votre taxe
foncière qui augmente ce n'est pas le
gouvernement c'est votre commune et
c'est un scandale je cite toujours quand
j'entends des élus qui osent dire que
c'est la faute du gouvernement des
propos condamnés par les associations
d'élus locaux et de nombreux sénateurs
notamment en séance cette semaine encore
regardez quand le sénateur LR jean-rmond
Hugonet a pris la parole il a dit
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait dépassé les
limite je cite et distendu un peu plus
encore le lien de confiance entre les
élus locaux et l'État et écoutez Jeanron
Hugonet en vérité le sujet central que
révèle cette insupportable polémique
c'est que nous constatons amèrement les
effets délétaires du phénomène de
recentralisation massive qui frappe de
plein FO nos collectivités et que les
maires n'ont plus qu'un seul levier
fiscal pour y faire face la taxe
foncière ouis c'est un sujet important
orien au cœur des revendications des
collectivités locales comment garantir
leur autonomie financière surtout he
quand ces villes n'ont plus de leviers
fiscaux écoutez le ministre des comptes
publics il rejette toute critique dans
ce dossier certains disent avoir été
contraint à cette augmentation par le
niveau de soutien de l'État c'est faux
et le n' aucun lien ni avec le niveau
des dotations de l'État ni avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
alors Pascal sal comment est-ce que vous
vous trancher ce débat qu'est-ce que
vous répondez au ministre qu'est-ce que
vous répondz peut-être aussi à Emmanuel
Macron à ses propos du 24 septembre qui
ont fait bondir on le disait ah ça c'est
vous avez bien raison de le
rappeler la date est pas pasodine oui
céit le SO élection sénatorial à
l'occationion du président de la
République qui qui qui
enfin volontairement volontairement
c'est pas un un écart de langage
volontairement prend comme cible les
collectivités territoriales il en prend
deux les collectivités territoriales en
disant que c'est de la responsabilité
l'augmentation qui a été sa propre
décision d'ailleurs c'est 7,1 he
l'augmentation sa propre décision tout
seul et de l'autre côté il envoie une
deuxième cible un soir d'élection
sénatorial avec les résultats c'est un
président de la République qui a un goût
mais alors vraiment peu prononcer pour
le
parlementarisme voilà on a on a un sujet
on a un sujet on a un président de la
République qui n'aime pas ses
parlementaires mais ça il faut que le
Président de la République il
s'habitue à apprécier et reconnaître des
hommes et des fans qui ne pensent pas
comme lui qui ne lui ressembl pas et je
vais vous le dire cette question de la
taxe foncière c'est honteux quand même
de de faire de renvoyer ça aux
collectivités territoriales seul son
gouvernement a pris cette décision et en
plus il utilise le 493 mais mais les
maires les maires quel que soit leur
étiquette politique quel que soit du
plus petit village à la plus grande
ville vous avez cité des villes mais ils
peuvent pas utiliser le 493 quand ils
rencontrent leurs administré et la taxe
foncière c'est 32 millions de
propriétaires en France on parle à
beaucoup de Français et on parle aussi
aux bailleurs sociaux sur sur ce que dit
le gouvernement le gouvernement rappelle
que les leviers fiscaux qui ont été
retirés aux collectivités locales elles
sont penser je cite à l'euro prêt en
fait l'exécutif il met peut-être aussi
les élus locaux devant leur
responsabilité s'ils souhaitent
augmenter les impôts qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ce raisonnement vous avez
fait un passage de du ministre casn
voilà vous pouviez pas vous pouviez pas
tout relater de son intervention moi je
je prends acte que le ministre a admis
que l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités avait été amoindri il l'a
dit et c'est quand même ça un principe
constitutionnel VO il a ditand en
revanche l'autonomie financière était
pas remis en cause il parle bien des des
des questions sur les leviers fiscaux
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai parlé de
l'autonomie fiscale sinon vous allez
finir pourre parole du ministre enfin
après chacun sa chacun prend sa place
dans dans dans dans tout ça mais non non
c'est c'est sérieux et les villes déjà
vous vous l'avez rappelé vous avez
raison qu vous avez la majorité 85 % des
m qui ne l'ont pas fait certains il y a
eu des augmentations sur la feuille on
le voit mais il y avait les taxes d'ord
ménagère voyez ce que je vouux vous dire
c'est pareil il faut de la rigueur faut
de la clarté quand on énonce quelque
chose le président de la République il
le sait il le sait tout ça normalement
normalement donc voilà c'est une
polémique c'est un contrat de défiance
vis-à-vis des collectivités territorial
et c'est un contrat de défiance
vis-à-vis des parlementaires et on
reparlera de ça bien sûr à l'occasion
des congrès des départements et aussi
des maires qui arrivent au mois de
novembre qu' suivra avec
vous merci merci merci Quentin à tout à
l'heure dans le club merci Pasqual sa
d'avoir éé notre invité pendant cette
première dem peut-être excusez-moi mais
on a abordé un sujet extrêmement grave
au début et j'ai j'ai cherché une petite
poésie Louis Aragon qui a été mis en
musique par Jean ferra et un moment
important parce que c'est le moment où
le fascisme triompit en
Espagne ça s'appelle un jour mais c'est
très connu un jour pourtant un jour
viendra couleur d'or un jour de palme un
jour de feuillage au front un jour
d'épaule nu où les g saimeront un jour
comme un oiseau sur la plus haute
branche j'aime pas envie qu'on perde cet
amour de l'humanité merci merci Pascal
savoldellie d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin